à partir du moment où il ya eu la chute
du mur de berlin l'effondrement de
l'urss
le rapport de force des classes
dominantes vis-à-vis de la population
s'est totalement déséquilibrée en faveur
de qui des classes dominantes parce
qu'il y avait effectivement une
tentation de la population des classes
populaires a basculé dans le communisme
à partir du moment où cette menace n'est
plus alors le rapport de force
déséquilibré totalement est en fait le
néo libéralisme n'est que la traduction
des râpes du rapport de force qui s'est
déséquilibré en faveur des élites et qui
leur a permis d'akkad d'accroître leur
prédation sur la richesse produite et
donc en france ça se traduit comment ça
te traduit par des classes dominantes
qui depuis trente ans ne prennent que
des mauvaises décisions nous envoie dans
le mur économiquement parce que il ya
les principes il ya la réalité la
réalité c'est que la croissance dans le
pays elle n'arrête pas de dégringoler
sur la dernière décennie on est
péniblement à 0 15%
le pib par habitant depuis 2008 ils
baissent de manière tendancielle et on a
ensuite deux éléments clés à prendre en
compte
1 les uns ou les 0 1% les plus riches
n'arrête pas d'exploser leurs revenus et
dans le même temps on a la population
française qui pour au moins 30 % d'entre
elles connaît une baisse du niveau de
vie au moins 30% parce que les chiffres
de l'insee sont peut-être sous-évalué
notamment dans la prise en compte de
l'inflation et du coût de l'immobilier
voilà la réalité et cette baisse du
niveau de vie elle va s'accentuer dans
les années à venir parce que comme on a
cassé notre appareil productif français
on ne pourra pas maintenir dans l'avenir
notre niveau de richesse
notre ni le niveau de vie de la
population et pourquoi on est un système
libéral n'est tout simplement parce
qu'on est dans l'union européenne et que
l'union européenne consacre le libre
échange via le marché unique dont qu'on
vienne m'expliquer qu'il n'y a pas de
dérégulation alors que le point central
du néolibéralisme c'est le libre échange
la mise en concurrence des pays les uns
envers les autres
quand bien même ces les niveaux de
développement de ces pays sont très
hétérogènes et donc en l'état pour
revenir à des choses très concrètes on a
un salaire minimum qui nous est à 1500
euros et on s'est mis en concurrence
libre échangisme avec la pologne par
exemple qui est un salaire minimum à 500
euros
comment voulez vous qu'on retienne les
entreprises françaises en france quand
les propriétaires ces entreprises
peuvent aller fabriquer leurs produits
trois ou quatre fois moins cher dans un
pays étranger
[Musique]